sigrid kaag has been bullied
I've had a stomachache for two days
what kind of country have we become
that a female politician is so intimidated
hated and threatened
that she must choose between her calling
and her safety
actually i know the answer
a dictatorship of the loudest screamers
kaag walked in body armor
through war zones and lectured dictators
but the Dutch abdomen
turns out to be the most dangerous of all
fellow politicians
and media are now tumbling over each other
to say how bad they all are
but what have they been doing in recent years
while kaag was threatened
I remember Jeroen Peacock
who asked galiet and sophie to kaag or
they threaten with burning torches
had not provoked himself
wilders who called her a traitor
and consistently dismissed her as a witch
which the telegraph took over all too eagerly
and some angry twittermen still post now
under the message of kaagsvertrek
with the accompanying
terrorist sweetheart and fire in hell
and why kaag was not responsible for
overheated files
as nitrogen the surcharges scandal
gas extraction or migration
but no it was not about what kaag does
but for who she is
a leader who keeps course
instead of blowing with the wind of the day
who does not adopt a different accent or clothing style
because she wants the voter to pick her on the content
who treats that same voter like an adult
by occasionally telling him or her the truth
and unfortunately because she is a woman
female politicians
systematically have more to do with verbal aggression
and threats
than their male colleagues
and it goes beyond their policies and positions
they are attacked on their personal identity
on their sex on their appearance
in the case of kaag
also often
on the fact that she married a Palestinian man
all things
who have nothing to do with their work at all
that is a serious threat to our democracy
because it takes away women
the right to political participation
and a democracy that it is a part of the population
possibly very difficult
to participate fully in the political process
is not a democracy
but a dictatorship
because despite all the statements of support and indignation
to the address of kaag
is that the message that sticks
harassment pays off
the media has not scratched its head
how they actually report about kaag
other political parties
have not resisted it sufficiently
and sometimes even boosted it
and social media
how could it be otherwise
have done nothing about it
for the hatred and intimidation of kaag
to counter
under the guise of freedom of speech
and a diverse public debate
give talk shows
newspapers and social
media give way to adolescent troublemakers
that guarantee them commercial success
the upcoming elections are therefore not running alone
about nitrogen or asylum policy
how much some parties like
want us to believe that too
no they are about the future
of our democracy
we choose a dictatorship
of the loudest screamers
or we settle difficult files
in a dialogue
we tolerate parties
who whip up their supporters
to intimidation and threats
to then hide behind the fact
that they never literally called for that
or do we draw a line
we accept
that women work in politics
made impossible
through all the hatred and intimidation that arises
get over him
purely because of the fact that they are women
or do we ensure that harassment no longer pays off
Kaag said in an interview with the nos
that she hopes her resignation
will not deter young girls
to enter politics
I am afraid this will be the case
and that cannot be blamed
no that can be blamed on all of us